this episode was brought to you by the
music for scientists album
now available on all streaming services
you can check out the music video for
the song
the idea at the link in the description
here at journey to the microcosmos we
have a small team of people
working to make these videos for you
every week first there's me
hi i'm hank green your narrator and then
there's james weiss our master of
microscopes
providing all of the beautiful footage
you see on your screen
matthew gaydos is our producer and
editor taking my narration and james's
footage and turning them into actual
videos that you can watch
and last but certainly not least is
daboki chakravarti our
writer on journey to the microcosmos the
person
who brings the microcosmos to life with
her storytelling and
her exhaustive research devoki has been
with the channel since almost the very
beginning in fact
the first script she ever wrote for
journey to the microcosmos was our
episode about
diatoms back in 2019
and since we're here today to discuss
diatoms once again
we thought it would be fitting to use
this opportunity to
introduce deboki's new role as another
host
of journey to the micro cosmos i'll
still be here narrating most of the
episodes but from time to time you'll
hear deboki hosting a video
instead of me with her experience not
only in writing over 70 episodes
of journey to the micro cosmos but also
with her phd
in biomedical engineering and as a host
on crash course organic chemistry
i could not be more excited to have her
join me
on this journey so now i'm going to hand
the microphone over to debokey
so she can teach you more about diatoms
wherever you are on your journey to the
micro cosmos
the odds are high that you'll run into a
diatom
they're both abundant and easy to spot
because of the shells they encased
themselves in
the results are beautiful exacting
geometries
that create a living kaleidoscope in the
microcosmos
and even if you lived your entire life
without ever seeing a diatom without
ever hearing the word diatom you would
still be living a life
that's shaped by them all the way down
to the oxygen you breathe
thanks in no small part to their
outsized contribution to the world's
photosynthesis
but what remains captivating about
diatoms is
well the thing that remains even when
the diatom itself is gone
the hard silica shell they once lived in
also known
as the frustule we've talked about
frustules a bit before
and how they've given diatoms the
nickname jewels of the sea
and today we're going to dive a bit more
into how those frustrals are made
and the role they play in our world
diatoms are the architects of their own
glass
houses and the scale of this project
is immense the silica shells aren't just
a smooth
uniform exterior there are pores
and elongated channels creating ornate
microscopic patterns that the organism
depends on to survive
[Music]
the source of the diatoms building
blocks is geology
as rocks and land get weathered and
eroded silica enters the water
where it dissolves into silicic acid
which can then diffuse into the diatom
and get converted into silica
but if diffusion isn't bringing in
enough material
the diatoms can also rely on silicon
transporter proteins in their membranes
to gather more
inside the diatom is a special area
called the silica deposition vesicle
and it's there that the silica bits get
linked together to form
bigger and bigger pieces but while we
know that this is
where the silica walls get put together
the chemistry and biology of
how they get put together is still
unclear
we know that the silica can itself form
a gel-like network
so that could make up a key assembly
step
but there may also be other organic
molecules like proteins that bind to the
silica and help create the final
structure
while scientists are still untangling
those mechanisms
they have observed the way that the
silica deposition vesicle
and other structures in the cell
including the mitochondria
can help to mold the shape of the final
silica structure
for example elongated symmetric diatoms
also called pennate diatoms often have a
slit called the rafi
the slit helps the diatom move around
serving as an
opening through which they can secrete a
viscous fluid
to glide on and one of the ways that
diatoms make the rafi
is by physically molding it through the
arrangement of their microtubules
many diatoms are non-modal meaning they
don't move around
and the lack of visible movement from
the outside is striking
when you consider all of the activity
that has gone on
inside of them to make those frustules
happen
[Music]
like we said earlier they're doing more
than creating a smooth
transparent surface they're creating a
molded
ornate structure personalized to their
own shape
like a house couture and
not only is this process a lot of work
it renders diatoms dependent on silica
a chemical they can't make for
themselves
so why do it well
for one it's cheaper than both making
and assembling your own materials
the silica is already out there so why
not take advantage of it
one study found that the materials in
the diatoms frustules might help the
organism take in carbon dioxide
improving their photosynthetic
capabilities
[Music]
these advantages seem to translate over
into the immense capacity of diatoms to
grow
and dominate over other algae that share
their waters but taking over a body of
water
is all fun and games until the silica
runs out
diatoms are known for their ability to
form large visible blooms
whether in your local lake or the arctic
ocean
but scientists studying those arctic
blooms found that
as the diatom population expanded
they also depleted their waters of
silicic acid
and that in turn halted their growth and
began to increase the number of dead
diatoms
[Music]
and both of these things the lack of
growth and the dying
have another impact on diatom
populations
sinking healthy growing diatoms can
up their buoyancy to keep them afloat
while dying cells
cannot it might be sad to imagine those
blooms
dying and descending to lower depths the
ornate jewels collapsing like a
microbial empire
but nature doesn't trade in
inconsequential tragedies
the death of diatoms leaves behind
frustules like this one
which means it leaves behind silica some
of that silica can be recycled by
other diatoms but over time it will
eventually descend
further and further down until it
gathers on sediments
when a diatom takes in silicic acid it's
taking in the remnants of a geological
process
the weathering and erosion that brought
the silicon to water in the first place
and then through the construction of its
shell it recycles and
transforms the dissolved silicon into a
form that can become geological
once again and how that silica gets used
again can vary
but as always with the diatom your
chances of running into it again
are high scientists found that dust from
a diatom shell-rich sediment in chad
might travel as far as the amazon
the diatom itself may not be making the
trip but
the microcosmos and the things built in
it
have a way of sticking around
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
this episode is brought to you by the
music for scientists album
which was created by composer and
musician patrick olson
the album is inspired by the
intersection of science and art
and if you're looking to explore that
intersection more
check out the music video for one of the
tracks on the album
called the idea the music video for this
track was produced from a sequence of
fifteen thousand photographs
of three traditional paintings by artist
john todd
his painting style was then transferred
to a video performance by using a form
of machine learning
and the song itself is all about
exploring how we form ideas
if you think this sounds like something
you might enjoy click the link in the
description
to see the video or stream the music on
all major music services
the names on the screen right now those
are our patreon patrons
without them we could not make this show
and we are so
thankful to them if you like what we do
and want to help us keep making it
you can join those people at patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you